こんにちはこんばんはーこちらスティーブカフェです
今日はですね日本人のあるや日本語を母国語としての方に対して特別なお願いがあり
ます
そのたくさんのまあ言葉を勉強して
うーんまたる私がですね非常に共通な点がたくさんあるんですよ
同じような概念同じような意味を表すのですね
その書く言葉ではあのますその形が
房色が違うけれどもそれ意味が
伝えたい意味が同じなんですよやりたい行きたい行くだろうか
これがこうだからこれが相談と
色々あるんでしょ共通のメッセージが非常にあるんですよ
それだからこの
言葉を勉強するために楽さんのストーリーをつくってそして
違ったそのパターンをその
いわゆる集中した形でこう
それでパターンを利用して
そしてこのストーリーを聴きながらこの
言葉を勉強するという新しいその勉強方法と同時にストーリー自体がですね
3つの部分に分かれて基本のストーリーと同じ通りは違った
その
[音楽]
立場違った人のたちあるいは
日本語の場合は違ったその
丁寧どうとかね間違った形での
同じ通りと所持最後はいろんな質問
市町に対して返事ねしかしこの辺人に対してはその返事まあこのストーリーの中でも
もう
その聴いてる人にあるいは読んでる人にはおっしゃしれるわけですよ言いますよ
だから園児数なより簡単だけども
共有方にするとですね非常に遺憾
3ですか往復ですね以上のニーソの
レペティションができるわけですよで私はこのシステムを今
bully 社語を勉強するために使ってるわけですよ大変もいいですよ
今芸者後は今までの勉強した言葉よりも
あの
早く僕は進歩しているような管理しています
だからそういうストーリーが今われわれがその作家に頼んでもう白い通りもう薬も
作ろうとしてるわけですよ
みんなもうし面白いストーリーそのストーリをいろんな外国語や英語会がいる
の言葉に翻訳してちょっと録音したいですよ
でそれに対しておりはう我々はボランティアがいるんですよ
ボランティアが
それで今まではスペイン語やポルトガル語ロシア語
ボランディアガーあるんですよ
しかし残念ながら日本人の日本語を母国語としてのボランティアがないです
ぜひ参加していただきたいんですよ
で参加する人には
5つのストーリーを翻訳して
2カ月間無料リンクを支える
そして5つのストーリーを録音すると
1月無料りんご付与できます
しかしそれよりもこのストーリーを読んだり聞いたり
処理から翻訳すると
そのエゴの基本のパターンを
そのマスターするにも非常に役みたいと思います
だから興味のある方いらっしゃれば
ぜひ私に連絡してください
それはあるいは3 ee
れインドトーンあるいはこの youtube の僕のビデオの下で
メッセージ残してくださいじゃあもし誰か
それに対して興味あり
教えてくださいじゃどうもさようなら
[音楽]
分
た
って
ん